did you pay your taxes this year if you
did you are a sucker
here are three clever and completely
legal ways to get the taxman the slip
the option option an executive is
negotiating his employment contract for
the coming years
the company might offer millions in
shares but who wants to pay taxes on
millions and shares better to take
options gains from non qualified stock
options the most common form aren't
taxed until the holder exercises them
that means the executive controls when
and whether the tax bill comes
it isn't just icing either often it's
the cake Larry Ellison CEO of Oracle
earned $1 in salary in 2013 and was
awarded seventy six million eight
hundred ninety three thousand six
hundred dollars in options the estate
tax Eliminator a wealthy parent with
millions invested in the stock market
wants to leave future earnings to his
kids but he wants to avoid the estate
tax on those earnings and who doesn't
step one the parent sets up a grantor
retained annuity trust or grat and list
the kids as beneficiaries step two when
the parent contributes say a hundred
million dollars to the grat Step three
profit whatever return the money earns
an excess of interest remains in the
trust and gets passed on to the heirs
three of the state and gift taxes
forever the no sale sale say an
executive has two hundred million
dollars of company shares he wants cash
but he doesn't want to pay the thirty
million dollars
so in capital gains taxes for selling
the executive borrows about two hundred
million dollars from an investment bank
and uses the shares as collateral now he
has cash to freeze the value of the
collateral shares he buys and sells
options granting him the right to buy
and sell the shares later at a fixed
price if he ends up keeping the cash he
has to hand over the shares but the tax
bill comes years after the initial
borrowing and his money has been working
for him the whole time